es ist die wahrscheinlich waghalsigsten
raumfahrt missionen der menschheit und
jetzt zum großen finale setzt die nasa
noch mal einen drauf zum schiff beginnt
die saturnsonde cassini kamikaze aber
vor diesen selbstmordkommando wird die
sonde von heute an noch einige
spektakuläre manöver fliegen und
erstmals auch proben vom saturn oder
seine atmosphäre nehmen wir das ganze
vonstatten gehen soll das große finale
jetzt in klicks um science-fiction
herzlich willkommen
es war eine schwere geburt die
schwierigsten herausforderungen gab es
bei dieser mission noch vor ihrem start
1997 mehrmals stand das projekt auf der
kippe
mit insgesamt mehr als drei milliarden
dollar war es den usa einfach zu teuer
und wurde immer wieder in frage gestellt
aber dann am 15 oktober 1997 startete
eine der ehrgeizigsten mission der
menschheit der saturn und seine monde
sollten erforscht werden und sogar eine
sonde auf dem saturnmond titan abgesetzt
werden alles klappte der länder
hooligans landete auf dem unwirtlichen
mond titan konnte sogar 72 stunden lang
daten senden zum ersten mal konnten so
bilder von titan gemacht werden die
dichte atmosphäre verhinderte dass bis
dahin der größte erfolg der mission
bisher auf dem saturnmond enceladus
wurden bedingungen für mögliches
außerirdisches leben entdeckt mehrmals
durch flokati die von ihr entdeckten
geysire des mondes und konnte darin
alles finden was leben um hydrothermalen
quellen herum ermöglichen wird und jetzt
kommt das große finale der mission
cassini geht der treibstoff aus und die
sonde wäre ohne ihn nicht mehr steuerbar
die nasa will jetzt unbedingt vermeiden
dass cassini einen mond mit der chance
auf leben kontaminiert und so die
forschung nach leben dort erheblich
erschweren würde deshalb soll die sonde
auf dem gasplaneten saturn stürzen auf
dem außerirdisches leben nahezu
ausgeschlossen werden kann aber darüber
werden wir in den nächsten wochen und
monaten mehr erfahren zum ersten mal
wird die sonde proben aus der atmosphäre
des zweitgrößten planeten
im sonnensystem nehmen und dafür wird
sie so tief wie noch nie eine sonde
zuvor über den planeten fliegen zwischen
dem innersten ring der sich hinunter bis
zu 2400 kilometern höhe über dem saturn
ausdehnt und eben der oberfläche erst
jetzt zum schluss der mission will die
nasa dieses hohe risiko eingehen denn
jetzt ist es auch egal selbst wenn etwas
schief geht und die sonde zb durch den
staub der vom saturn ständig aus dem
inneren ring angezogen wird bestätigt
wird sind die folgen nicht schlimm denn
am ende soll es nämlich sowieso so
aussehen das milliarden teure raumschiff
soll in der atmosphäre verglühen
stichtag dafür ist der 15 september 2017
wir werden euch natürlich hier bei pixum
darüber ausführlich informieren wenn er
das und alles andere nicht verpassen
wollt dann solltet ihr hier genau ein
abo aufsaugen vergesst nicht den auf die
glocke wenn er bisher noch kein klicks
um abo hatte dann habt ihr das alles
verpasst aber es ist noch nicht zu spät
drauf klicken und die besten videos von
klick zum anschauen also bis dann bleibt
dran